King Joffrey has finally got his
comeuppance but who did it let's look at
who was in a position to off Joff hey
fellow Game of Thrones fans it's Jan
here for flicks in the city what is it
about Game of Thrones and whacking
people at weddings
first the Starks got it in the neck in
season three's red wedding and then
Joffrey got all choked up in season
fours purple wedding okay so nobody died
at Tyrion and Sansa's wedding but it
wasn't exactly a barrel of laughs now
was it and don't forget Jaime
Lannister's gentle reminder to Loras
Tyrell that if Loras actually married
Cersei she'd murder the knight of
flowers in his sleep anyone would think
that george RR martin had something
against marriage anyway the big question
the purple wedding left us with was who
killed Joffrey so just who are Westeros
is most wanted yes Tyrion has been
accused of killing his nephew by Cersei
who says that Joffrey pointed his uncle
as he died he does have plenty of
reasons to loathe Joffrey not least the
relentless humiliation he suffered
during the wedding festivities including
the sick spectacle of the war of the
five kings he did have plenty of
opportunity as the Kings cup bearer at
the wedding and Sansa does flee the
scene of the crime maybe because she
knew what her husband had done or maybe
because Tyrion had arranged for her to
get out of harm's way in case he was
caught but we all know that Tyrion has
an unfortunate history of being accused
of crimes he didn't commit
remember Catelyn accusing him of brans
attempted assassination and Lysa
accusing him of murdering her husband
Jon Arryn the King's hand prior to Ned
Stark okay so he did tell his Squire
Podrick to pay the dwarf entertainers
after the wedding adding that we'll have
to find another way to thank the king
with a low Tyrion smaller stature he's
big in brain which means he'd been way
too clever to put himself so obviously
in the firing line had he actually done
the deed I don't think he'd be standing
around picking up the incriminating
goblet after the event
with mother of madness earthy on the
case let's just say he's gonna need a
good lawyer or alternately someone a bit
skillful in a skirmish to fight from in
a trial by combat situation just like
bran did in the Eyrie and so to the
bride Margaery Tyrell certainly knows
her way around the politics of power she
married Renly Baratheon despite knowing
he was a lover of her brother Loras
she went over Joffrey with flattery when
Loras asked him to marry her and
repayment for the Terrell's helping the
Lannisters win Blackwater and she's
warned her
I heart Joffrey t-shirt well ever since
then with a little slip in episode 1 of
season 4 when she commented
sarcastically to her grandmother Lenna
that if Joffrey chose her wedding
necklace it had probably be made of dead
Sparrow heads based on her own
experience and Sansa's she was fully
aware of the nature of the beast she was
marrying maybe she saw that if she were
going to tear herself willingly into the
lion's den it would be wise to make sure
the one with the most vicious bite was
out of the way yeah she's been able to
control Joffrey up to this point getting
him to wave to his people and give his
leftovers to the poor but how long would
it be before he'd be beyond her control
has happened to Cersei I mean just look
at Joffrey's disgusting reenactment of
the war of the five kings and his
treatment of Tyrion at the feast with
Joffrey dead it's likely Margery
Woodward his much better behaved brother
Tommen game says a match Margaery then
oh and she certainly had her chance to
dispense with the malicious monarch
after all she was beside him throughout
the wedding festivities handle of his
gold goblet and even fed him his pie and
she didn't rush to his side to help him
like Cersei did as he lay dying on the
floor also was Joffrey pointing at
Tyrion who was he actually pointing at
Margaery plus getting rid of Circe's
pride and joy with doubtless give
Margaery a bit of added revenge on her
mother-in-law for her rains of castamere
threat last season could granddaddy
Tywin have tired of Joffrey as
terrifying as Tywin is with Joffrey
really care before him for much longer
could he really have continued to order
the king to his chambers once he was a
married man perhaps
Tywin thought it was time for more
likeable
to take the Iron Throne and therefore
make is live from positioners hand
easier but most importantly the new
blood would be pliable step forward
Tommen it's your turn
interestingly enough if you look really
closely you can see Tywin protects
Tommen from seeing Joffrey die
so how would Tywin have done it well the
man's a master of machination and it's
not like he doesn't have experience with
this sort of wedding now is it perhaps
then you saw that Tywin gifted Joffrey
for his wedding was actually laced with
poison
so when Joffrey used it to cut the
wedding pie it poisoned the pc8 the dead
dove we see in the pie was doubtless
caused by Joffrey striking with his
sword but it's still an interesting way
to foreshadow his death but with an
others have eaten the pie at the feast
and therefore been affected too well yes
but we never actually see anyone eat the
pie though we do see a Lenna and Tywin
with a fork full of something but surely
as King Joffrey would be the first to
scoff down his piece and well once
you've seen the King drop dead after
eating his pie I'm guessing that might
put you off yours
and remember Joffrey's new sword the
widow's wail if he names it was actually
melted down from Ned Stark's sword ice
and wouldn't that just be a delightful
irony the kind that Tywin would
doubtless in joy to know that Joffrey
died by the same blade that killed Ned
Stark the sword may not have caused the
widow's well this time but it certainly
led a mother to mourn the red priestess
is definitely dark and full of terrors
but was it really miss Scarlett with a
black magic in the dining room let's
look at the evidence she's been involved
in a death by poisoned wine before
remember maester Cressen in season 2 who
tried to poison Melisandre well they
both drank the same poisoned wine but
Melisandre is fine while Cresson keeled
over blood trickling from his nose then
there's Melisandre's attempt to show
Stannis Baratheon the power of Kings
blood using the blood of Gendry Robert
Baratheon's bastard son
she had Stannis throw leeches fat with
gendry's blood into fire while naming
three usurpers he wanted dead the men he
named were Robb Stark Balon Greyjoy and
Joffrey Baratheon
well robbing Joffrey are already dead so
is Stannis and Rey the dark force behind
Joffrey's earthly departure or was it
just coincidence
beylin Greyjoy I hope so Sansa certainly
had more than enough reasons to do away
with a king he beheaded her father in
front of her despite agreeing to show
mercy and later forced her to look at
Ned's head on a spike and when she
initially refused he had one of his men
strike her he threatened her with a
crossbow in front of the whole court
before ordering her to be beaten and his
lies about the incident with ayah and
butchers boy Micah led to Santa's dire
wolf lady being killed
not to mention Joffrey's persistent
jibes during his wedding about her dead
family and that disgusting display of
Robb Stark's death in the war of the
five kings the list is endless and she
certainly had the opportunity remember
when Joffrey kicked his gold goblet away
from Tyrion to humiliate his new
cupbearer well it went under Sansa's
table and it was Sansa who picked it up
and handed it back to Tyrion perhaps
that gave her just enough time to
secrete something sinister in the goblet
and there's the fact that people who
flee the scene of a crime tend to look a
little bit guilty but she does seem a
little surprised when Dontos turns up to
take her away and let's face it she
hasn't exactly displayed the same killer
instinct as her sister Arya yes he's got
motive
remember Joffrey was going to have him
drowned in wine in season 2 until Sansa
and the Hound intervened telling the
king it would be bad luck to kill
someone on his name day and when Dontos
performed at the wedding of the Kings
fool Joffrey egged on the crowd to Pelt
him with food plus dantas was there
ready to whisk off Sansa once the king
hit the deck telling her that if she
wanted to live she had to leave and then
there's a small matter of the necklace
Dontos gave Sansa in Episode one of
season four
why was he quite so insistent she take
it do you believe that family heirloom
story he was at the wedding festivities
as well so maybe he could have
interfered with the feast after all he
does know his way around a barrel of
wine but surely dantas is too much of a
drunken fool to orchestrate the death of
the king by himself right ah Petyr
Baelish one of the most dangerous and
least trustworthy men in Westeros and
then whose influence is felt everywhere
he's been conspicuous by his absence in
F
so is one and two of season four okay so
his ship is supposed to have left the
Vale of Arryn in season three but just
because he doesn't seem to be around
doesn't mean events are beyond his
control
after all like Varys he has his spies
for example male prostitute Oliver who
after sleeping with Loras in season
three found out about the Tourelles plan
to marry Loras to Sansa and this season
Oliver's been keeping Oberyn Martell
entertained and Littlefinger informed -
no doubt
so did Littlefinger have a hand in
Joffrey's death well he's certainly
devious enough to do so and he's given
himself a great alibi by not attending
the wedding and it wouldn't be the first
time he's tried to frame Tyrion
Lannister either who was it after all
who told Catelyn Stark that the dagger
used in brans attempted assassination
actually belonged to Tyrion and that
Tyrion had won it from Littlefinger in a
bet exactly
but why would he slay the sovereign
think back to that conversation
Littlefinger and Varys had about the
realm in season 3 you know the one where
Littlefinger says that chaos is a ladder
many who try to climb it fail and some
are given the chance to climb but they
refuse they cling to the realm or the
gods or love illusions only the ladder
is real the climb is all there is
obviously Littlefinger is an aficionado
of chaos and the more chaos the merrier
and murdering a monarch is pretty high
up there when it comes to creating chaos
chaos which would doubtless create many
opportunities to Littlefinger to climb
higher and higher that ladder just as
the chaos of war allowed him to rise to
lord of harrenhal
after he arranged the turell's to
support the Lannisters of Blackwater so
what would Littlefinger hope to gain
specifically from Joffrey's death well
if Dantas was whisking off Sansa to
little finger then Littlefinger would
control what many characters think is
the only remaining stark and therefore
the key to the north which would mean
more power to little fingers elbow or
should that be finger he's already tried
to takes answer away before but she
declined don't forget that rose warned
Shae and Varys about Littlefinger having
his eye on the eldest stark daughter and
we all know how that's ended for us this
time though Sansa had little choice
about leaving as it might not be long
before the finger of suspicion was
pointed at her for Joffrey's death and
remember Littlefinger was infatuated
with santa's mother Catelyn but his love
was unrequited wouldn't he therefore
relish controlling Kats beautiful
daughter Sansa and it would also give
him some revenge
just like when he betrayed cats husband
Ned so how would he have done it
worded drunken Don toss get that
necklace from and why did he actually
give it to Sansa couldn't the real point
of the necklace have been to smuggle
poison into the wedding without raising
suspicion and if the plan were
discovered Sansa would make the perfect
Patsy the certainly see has been no
limit to what Littlefinger will do to
get what he wants
as Varys told her Lenna tyrell
Littlefinger would see this country burn
if he could be king of the ashes oh boy
the more you think about it the more it
seems that Petyr Baelish his
fingerprints are all over this but
wouldn't he have needed someone reliable
at the wedding to make sure the poison
ended up in the right place now did he
notice that during the wedding ceremony
when the Septon says cursed be he who
would seek to tear them asunder we get a
lovely shot
focused on a Lenna and Loras Tyrell
Oberyn Martell and pycelle behind
Margaery and Joffrey hmm
intriguing and so to the Tyrell
matriarch we know Alana's a woman of
both wit and wealth she isn't afraid to
speak her mind she's shrewd enough to be
able to deal with Tywin Lannister and
like him she's a master political power
gains but why would she want to bump off
her grand son in law well she's
obviously not impressed with Joffrey's
behavior to say the least
Sansa called him a monster when Elena
asked her what she thought of him and
did you see the look on Alana's face at
the end of the dwarf entertainment a
smart cookie like a Lenna could see that
Margaery would only be able to control
the king so far with Joffrey gone
Margaery would be set to marry the much
more malleable next in line to the Iron
Throne
Tommen therefore Elena would keep
Margaery away from Joffrey's crossbow
while still joining the royal bloodline
which would help house Tyrell grow
strong so how would she have done it
well Elena was definitely fiddling with
something in her hands as she spoke to
Tywin on the way to the feast
could it have been a little something to
add to Joffrey's wine but she's too
clever to risk it being seen
isn't she she also makes a point of
touching Sansa's hair and neck as she
console's her about her brother Rob's
death telling her that war is war but
killing a man at a wedding horrid what
sort of monster would do such a thing
a lennick could have taken this
opportunity to pick up something
previously planted on Sansa to do in
Joffrey drunken fool Dantas did insist
Sansa take his family necklace as a
thank-you for saving his life and she's
clearly wearing it at the wedding but
what's this is that a stone missing from
the necklace after Elena first / Sansa I
think it is and what's that little clink
we hear and that little motion of the
arm we see is Elena walks past
Marjorie's table did she pass the poison
stone from Sansa's necklace on to
Margaery or into Joffrey's goblet
so kuda Lenape in cahoots with
Littlefinger she'd certainly be a
reliable person to have on the ground
and the Terrell's have much to gain when
no one does anything to aid the choking
Joffrey Elena does order the wedding
guests to help their king was this a
genuine desire to help or a clever way
to take suspicion from herself if a
learner were behind this plot all this
would come with a delicious side serving
a retaliation on Tywin for forcing Loras
to marry Cersei which scuppered Elena's
plans to marry him - Sansa in season 3
season 4 marks the first time we've seen
mace Tyrell on screen Lord of Highgarden
and head of one of the richest families
in Westeros mace was keen on increasing
his family's prestige by wedding his
daughter Margaery to Joffrey
surely that means he wouldn't have
knocked off his new son-in-law then add
to that the fact that according to his
mother Elena he's a ponderous oaf who
places food above fighting and we seem
to be raising him from the list of
suspects but hold on his wedding gift to
Joffrey was a Gold Cup right yes but it
wasn't the gold goblet that Jeff was
drinking from when he croaked still when
Mae skipped off his wedding gift he did
say may you drink deep and live long
well Joffrey certainly drank deep he
wasn't quite so good at the living long
part though was this just a case in the
show foreshadowing Joffrey's death or
was mace in on the murderous plan he was
sat next to Joffrey during the wedding
gift presentations
could he have poisoned the kingdom with
a slow-acting potion is it possible that
fat head may
has more upstairs and a Lenna gives him
credit for but what about a motive
well his motive would be the same as a
Lehner's that is to protect Marjorie
while keeping the crown and now the
brother of the bride Loras was possibly
an earshot when Joffrey called Renly a
deviant at his wedding feast and told
Brienne he'd Knight the man who put a
sword through Renly add to that the
butt-naked dwarf running about as Renly
in Joffrey's vile entertainment which
led to Loras leaving the wedding table
in disgust and the fact that Joffrey
told Margaery in season 3 that he was
considering making homosexuality
punishable by death and brother laureth
has some possible motives but if Loras
didn't do the deed himself but his
family say Margaery and Elena did do you
really think they'd have let Loras in on
it probably not after all he did give
the game away to Littlefinger spy and
prostitute Oliver about their plans to
marry Loras off to Sansa thus ruining
the tyrell plot so Loras is probably off
the list of suspects since we first met
over in Martell aka the red Viper in
episode 1 of season 4 it's been pretty
obvious that he's not exactly the
Lannisters biggest fan of course he's
not the only one in the show who could
definitely live without hearing the
rains of castamere but he has harbored a
long-standing grudge against House
Lannister
for their part in the death of his
sister Elia and her kids
remember that Elia who was married to
Prince Rhaegar Targaryen was raped and
killed by Gregor Clegane aka the
mountain when the Lannisters sacked
King's Landing just before Robert
Baratheon became King but why kill
Joffrey why not just knock off the
mountain an eye for an eye maybe maybe
the King's death is just the start
Oberyn blames Tywin and his family for
the deaths of Elia and her children as
it believes that Gregor would not have
acted without Tywin's consent and as
Oberyn told Tyrion when they first met
the Lannisters aren't the only ones who
pay their debts
then there was that verbal sparring
session between Cersei Tywin Oberyn and
his lover Alaris and at the wedding
where they traded mutual insults that
culminated in what could be viewed as a
veiled threat by Oberyn against surtees
daughter Myrcella who was shipped off to
Dorne in season two to be Mary
to oberyn's nephew this is what Oberon
said to Cersei in some places the
highborn frown upon those of low birth
in other places the rape and murder of
women and children is considered
distasteful what a fortunate thing for
you former Queen Regent that your
daughter miss Ella has been sent to live
in the latter sort of place so could he
have been helped by a lorry and his plot
to rid the realm of Joffrey yes he's
Joffrey's real father but does that
really matter in a world where siblings
sleep together brother kills brother and
father scorns son it's not like Joffrey
wasn't known for getting right under
people's skin just look at how he
taunted Jaime in episode 1 of season for
saying that Jaime had never done
anything worthy of being recorded in the
history book of the Kingsguard
and look how depressed Jaime is in
episode 2 of season 4 about being unable
to fight since losing his sword hand but
come on with Jaime have really offed JA
after all he's the first one to go to
Joffrey side when the young King falls
to the ground fatherly instinct or just
doing his job his position as a maester
a man of science and medicine among
other things means that pycelle has
access to all sorts of potions and
poisons and Cersei is kneeling of him at
the wedding festivities telling him that
his every breath annoys her when exactly
have put him in a good mood but then
again he was sent away from the wedding
by Cersei who ordered him to tell the
kitchens to give the leftovers from the
feast to the kennels so that means he
was out of the way and couldn't have
done it right not exactly as we do later
see pycelle sitting opposite Varys
during the mock tournament could he have
been involved then in the murderous
plots
ok we all know what a wily character
pycelle is pretending he's a bit deaf or
a bit old and creaky as the situation
requires and then leaping to life when
no one's around but Tywin's on to his
little game and pycelle seems way too
intent on keeping his head down and
toting up to whoever's in power to risk
his neck killing the king no wonder he's
been a grand maester for so many years
did he notice how comfortable Varys
looked during the wedding festivities
most of the guests were clapping when
Marjorie announced leftovers from the
feast were going to the poor when the
dwarf entertainers arrived when dwarf
Rob stark was killed in front of Sansa
and when dwarf Joffrey humped Rob's
direwolf head but Faris didn't join in
he just looked rather on edge
now of course Joffrey's vile
entertainment would be enough to make
anyone uneasy but isn't beerus often
better at hiding what he thinks than
that is it possible the spiders spent a
wily web to kill Joffrey judging by his
refusal to lie to the Lannisters about
Shae when Tyrion asked him to it doesn't
seem likely he'd have the balls to off
Joff so maybe his unease at the wedding
was actually down to his knowledge that
someone else had a plot in motion after
all he does have his little birds just
before we leave you let's remind
ourselves as some appropriate wise words
from dwight schroot of the office it's
never the person you most suspect it's
also never the person you least suspect
since anyone with half a brain will
suspect them the most therefore I know
the killer to be the person I most
medium suspect so who do you most medium
suspect tell us in the comments below
and while you're at it remember to like
our video and subscribe to flicks in the
city for tons more Game of Thrones
reviews and interviews and remember if
you're not watching Jan G on Jyoti you
know nothing